On Earth. If you were to fall
into it's magma filled center,
your body would quickly bubble
up and disappear without a trace.
So if they're so good at
getting rid of things,
why aren't we using them to get rid of
our garbage? Has anyone tried it before?
How would we transport all our trash to
them and what dangers would be involved?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we
dumped our trash into volcanoes.
Americans alone generate about 254
million tons of trash per year,
and although dumping it into volcanoes
might sound like the perfect way to get
rid of it,
it wouldn't be that easy.
Volcanoes might look like
nature's garbage incinerators,
but in reality they're much
more dangerous and unstable.
Not to mention a lot harder to get to.
Would overcoming these obstacles be
worth it or would dumping our trash in
volcanoes just cause even
more harm to our planet?
The first obstacle in our quest for
volcanic garbage disposal would be finding
an active volcano that
can get the job done.
There are only about 1500 potentially
active volcanoes worldwide and most of
them aren't located anywhere near humans.
For obvious reasons.
That means getting all our trash to
an active volcano could turn out to be
pretty expensive,
and once we get there,
we might find out it's not even
the right kind of active volcano.
The kind of volcano we'd be looking
for is called a shield volcano,
a slow erupting variety that contains
the iconic lava lakes that gradually spew
out onto the earth. Unfortunately,
these aren't very common.
You're more likely to come across.
They're angry cousins known
as straddle volcanoes.
Straddle volcanoes are known for their
explosive eruptions caused by the buildup
of pressure from hot gas and magma.
In other words,
they're probably not the safest
location for the town dump,
but let's say we're lucky enough to find
ourselves a nice act of shield volcano
before we worry about the logistics
of getting our trash there.
Let's figure out if it's even
a good idea to dump it inside.
If you are one of the first
waste collectors hired to
drive up to the vent of a
volcano, you'd quickly start to
question your career choices.
The vent of a volcano is a treacherous
environment full of poisonous gases,
Lavis splatter and projectile rocks and
things only get worse once you start
throwing stuff inside.
In 2002 a group of Ethiopian researchers
through a 30 kilogram bag of trash into
a volcano and the results were explosive.
Lava lakes are unstable.
So if you pierce surfaces with
something cold like trash,
you'll trigger a chain reaction
of explosions involving
pressurized and acidic
steam.
So can you imagine how big
these explosions would be
if you through an entire
nations trash in there? Well,
to put it in perspective,
rock falls into level. Lakes and Hawaii
have sent lava 85 meters into the air,
so it probably look something like that.
Even if you could safely get
your trash into the volcano,
you'd still have to worry about all the
air pollution created by burning our
waste without filters.
Plus,
not all materials will
completely break down in lava,
which means that the polluting remnants
could erupt out and contaminate the
surrounding landscape. Not Ideal. If
you were hoping to burn nuclear waste,
for example,
add these environmental impacts on top
of the fact that shipping all our trash
to these volcanoes would significantly
increase the carbon footprint of the
waste disposal and the whole
thing looks like a terrible idea.
If we're going to burn our trash,
why not at least do it someplace where
we can use the heat released through
incineration to create
new sources of energy,
or instead maybe we could just
shoot our garbage out into space.
Surely there can't be any harmful
effects there. Right. Well,
that's a topic for another.
What if.